今天的内容有点难
然后你可能需要思考并就是反复思考
否则的话呢这个看了和没看之间是没有什么区别的
所以他并不是适合所有人
我介意大家找一关笔然后找一个指然后反复化两笔
然后我说的卖一点
可能会有一些不一样的生活
那么高手和普通的区别是什么
我认为是死定模型
所以我特别喜欢看一个人在创作一个产品的时候
当时发生什么
他当时的想法是什么
他所处的环境是什么
他为什么会这么做
为什么会做出这样的选择
而不是那样的选择
我们举个例子比如说
我们今天在抖音上去记得没有什么
那我更关注的其实不是抖音拍手的记得
我更关注于
抖音的价值关系什么
他的世界关系什么
他是怎么被创造出来的
我常常把自己推回到二人一六年二人一五年
他是怎么做出这个抖音来的
于是我就把
当时张英老师对外的所有的公开演讲
然后讲做然后分享包括写的文章
我都会认真的开演员
然后常常在里面找到一些组织码器
把自己带入到当时那个世界
然后常常出去解决他为什么会这样做
为什么会得出这样的一个选择
我们给大家举个例子
在二人一五年的时候的话
张英老师曾经给一本书写了一个续演
在续演里面他有这么一个短化
那我拿出来
摘曲一部分
端张曲意给大家读一读
他说什么呢说
互联网上的四大夫
哪四大夫呢
信息获取
社交
娱乐游戏
购买娱支付
我再来一边二个信息获取
社交
娱乐游戏
购买娱支付
与就说
在二人一五年的时候
张英老师这么看待回来网的
他是有四个部分主上的
哪四个部分主上呢
我们可以把他解化为
人和人的联级联级就是什么呢就是社交
人和信息的联级
对吧就是信息获取
人和娱乐的联级就是娱乐游戏对吧
人和消费的联级就是商业服务
和支付对吧
但是四条赛道
我们把自己
长时的段入当时那个视角
然后再去看过古连网
我会看到每家公司的布局
是什么样子的我们举个例子
我们拿A和T这两家具有代表性的巨头
来信拆信
当然一个是
杭州的爸爸一个是深圳的爸爸
是吧
我们来看一下A
那么A的话就有那些产品比如说
猛猛
猛猛对吧
他是做什么呢人和消费的
猛酷
猛影业
他是做人和娱乐的
然后猛波
然后猛C
他是做人和信息的
猛猛
他做的是
人和人的联级
好我们千万到另外一个嘛吧
对吧
那么早出其中的一个产品具有代表性的产品
比如说猛树
他的版本根本也可以看到他的布局
比如说
1.0到3.0这个版本
他做的是人和人的联级
然后4.0
他做的什么呢做的是人和信息的联级
5.0他做的是人和娱乐的联级
6.0做的是人和消费的联级
好翻过头来我们再回头看一下
自己跳动家公司
他的整个商业币环是怎么够结的
你看他有头条
是什么呢是人和信息的联级
然后他有
抖音气度美好生活是人和娱乐的联级
然后他有多少是人和人的联级
那么现在还在做什么呢
在做待货
在做出窗
然后渡到是入住抖音然后开始直播待货
就是什么呢
人和消费的联级
同时我们还会发现一个信号
什么信号呢就是
我们很多人那个手机的这个全现一定可以拍摄5分钟
不再是15秒钟
不再是60秒
而是长时更长
那么这个时候就可以包含更多的信息
大家看到了吗
人和信息的联级
人和娱乐的联级
人和人的联级
和人和消费的联级
那么有两个
有两个联级啊他的刚刚起步
那我相信的话他是一边做
然后一边看数据到一边持续感信
所以我们这个时候不防
和他一起找
甚至我们走个更快一点
领先一步我们去尝试去试错
当然大概如果我们先一步的话呢
走个人并不是那么多
然后你就没有那么多的借借
但是
因为你走得比较早
可能会顾途一点
但是你会更早到他那个位置
所以这个时候
不防
欺败产
等我封来